Dossey dhalsim um look we're having a
little bit of a problem from a marketing
standpoint it says here in your bio you
are a yoga practitioner I'm a master
practitioner of the spiritual art of
yoga okay see that's what we're having a
problem with just selling you to the
people is you're a master practitioner
of the spiritual art of yoga and yet you
want to enter a street fighting
tournament yes I will meditate and then
destroy my enemies okay you can see how
that's a little bit confusing on our end
of things we don't we don't know how to
sell you they will love me for my yoga
flame okay see right there that doesn't
make any sense you're doing an
incredibly violent thing but saying yoga
before it doesn't make it part of your
spiritual practice I do not do the
disconnect would it be okay if I bash
you in the face with the two-by-four
just as long as before I do it I say
Pilates listen I use my yoga to fight
for peace peace your big piece got big
piece gay are those piece skulls you're
wearing sorry come again around your
neck or those are those piece skulls the
jewelry the human human skull jewelry
you have oh these guys yeah um yeah
these are P skulls those are human
skulls and they're very very small if
those are baby skulls I don't even want
to know I couldn't begin to describe
that to legal okay well in yoga does a
lot of like different kinds of things
that are considered like okay to do some
people would say that you can't do yoga
on a full stomach and then some people
say that it's okay to wear baby skulls
around your neck and you see this is
completely unsellable we can't do
anything with this are you talking about
I'm totally marketable people love yoga
right now it's so hot these yoga
students all over the place I'm a
fighter people are fighting yoga fighter
I'm the guy right now you know it's
confusing to me is you're wearing skulls
and a bindi what do you know what a
bindi is yeah totally know what Phineas
you're a yogi from India I'd imagine
you'd know what a bindi is I do know
what it is point here bindi just go
right now yeah give it a quick point
now that that's your nipple that's
that's your that's your penis it's this
ah the physical representation of your
third eye yep that's what it is physical
representation of the third eye do you
even know what yoga is mm-hmm
tell me tell me what yoga is well it's
the one where you stretch a lot mm-hmm
doesn't Matt know there's a map you'll
get Froyo afterwards uh you sound like a
middle-aged mom who took one class at
the Y no I've been training for years
years years uh-huh uh-huh
all told off and on two years two years
yoga master it's hard to get up early in
the morning plus you know how it is with
work and then my yoga teacher got a job
in Connecticut then I couldn't okay I
didn't like the new guy we're gonna have
to rethink your entire image
maybe the play is we just own it you're
dhalsim the weird kind of spiritual
stretchy guy who punches and can
probably suck his own dick take that to
marketing see what they say if we pass
there's always killer instinct all right
Yoga see that makes no sense
Yoga is one thing teleporting is it yoga
lame yoga lame